fresh feared fee food colorful
vegetables and tomato uh it's perfect
hi I'm Matthew Francis I'm a tasty
producer and I'm gonna show you how to
make my favorite dish of all time
cioppino
it's Pride Month this is my favorite way
to celebrate
cioppino is a hearty seafood and tomato
stew
cioppino was first invented in San
Francisco California legend has it the
Italian fishermen were catching fish to
sell at the market and they would have
bycatch in their nets like scallops
squid mussels clams but back in those
fisherman's times it was the gross
see-through that no one wanted so the
fishermen decided to make a seafood stew
for themselves to enjoy and that is how
cioppino was born to me cioppino is the
dish that represents my coming out
journey I came out to my family when I
was 18 I was very terrified but it was
just finally the time to get it off my
chest we were sitting at a restaurant
and I wanted to try something different
to really remember that day and what I
chose was cioppino and that's why it
holds a special place in my heart after
coming out I've truly blossomed as an
individual I've gone to culinary school
I've worked in restaurants I've dated
boys every new city that I've lived in
it was so interesting to see all the
different types of Japan oh that are all
across the country and it's followed me
every step of the way if you use good
kosher salt good fresh cracked pepper
that's all the seasoning you need you
want to be able to taste the freshness
of the seafood now if you want to make
this easy on yourself you can just put
all the seafood into the pot and simmer
it with your stew but I want to be fancy
with this and plate it really beautiful
so I'm gonna sear all the fish
individually I'm extra I know it okay I
don't take it for granted that my life
is easier because of the people who came
before me so even though it's really
great to celebrate the progress that
we've made we still have so much more to
go with in the queer community not
everyone is treated equally in order to
grow we need to fully support each other
and I feel like the only way to really
change a person's opinion is just
through conversation so now you're gonna
steam your clams and your
with some white wine let them cook until
they pop open that's when you know
they're ready come on little buddy pop
open there you go all that leftover
buttery garlic seafood infused white
wine dump that right into your cioppino
broth it just makes the cioppino
out-of-this-world
I'm very proud to be gay because young
queer kids aren't what society tells
them they need to be which means they
really have to learn who they are in the
world at a very young age and that self
discovery has really made me the
interesting vibrant and ambitious person
that I am it's allowed me to not seek
society's approval to really find my own
value from within and use that to
inspire and motivate the work that I do
and cioppino has been there every step
of the way it's become a little
tradition for me to make a great batch
of cioppino for my friends during Pride
Month this is my favorite dish of all
time and I'm so happy I got to share it
with all of you man that's good go forth
and be gay make some cioppino happy
pride oh yes
you